joining us now with reaction to men who
have seen this violence face-to-face the
aforementioned Rudy Peters the
Republican congressional candidate from
California attacked by a knife wielding
Trump hater just on Sunday along with
House Majority Whip Steve Scalise of
course we all know over a year ago
congressman Scalise himself was shot has
endured multiple surgeries during that
Congressional baseball game not so far
from where we're broadcasting tonight
both of you it's wonderful to see you
for this very important topic Rudy I
want to start with you and then we're
gonna go to congressman Scalise tell us
very briefly what happened on Sunday
that all Americans must know given the
tenor of this debate and discourse today
yeah well thanks for having me Laura
sunday was just another day at the fair
and the street fair wonderful people in
Castro Valley great job by the Chamber
I had Anna another gentleman running for
Assembly District 20 here in California
with me all of a sudden were sitting
behind the table it's late in the
evening and we hear somebody scream and
fu Donald Trump fu Donald Trump we kind
of look up from the table he's got his
middle finger extended and he's walking
by our booth and we pretty much didn't
didn't say a word just watched him walk
by kind of keep an eye on him the next
thing we know he stops turns around and
says I'll show you and he pretty much
bum-rush as the table on our table we
had a coffee cup that had flags and ink
pens where we're registered and Alameda
County voters as he picks up the coffee
cup I kind of get away from the table
and start going around you know to the
front of the table he picks up the
coffee cup rares back throws it at us
misses it hits the ground breaks us or
pretty much chest to chest at this time
I grab him throw him to the ground I
don't strike him I don't even fall on
top of him I'm just standing over him
and backing up he busts he had a beer in
his hand with in glass bottle and people
were screaming children are screaming
and you know it's pretty crowded with
family and he jumps immediately up
reaches in his pocket pulls out a knife
and he's got it over his head and he's
screaming I'm gonna
to UM f4 I'm gonna kill you so he's he's
dancing in a circle and I can see his
thumb trying to get the blade he's
pushing on the button to try to get the
blade to come out so at that point I'm
pretty much fearing for my life so I
just looked around and grabbed kind of a
sign at another vendors booth a little
plastic kind of like a sandwich board
sign and held it I thought you know when
this lunatic gets you know gets through
this knife out he's gonna kill me so
unless somebody finally screamed and
yelled and it stopped and he turned
around and left and I went back to my
booth I mean I Rudy this is insane first
of all we're so glad you're safe
glad the switchblade was not operating
or he didn't know how to operate it but
congressman Scalise of course I thought
about you the first moment I heard about
this read about it I thought about you
and everything you and your family have
gone through over this past year your
reaction to this entire trajectory since
the last year to today given what's
happened well Laura first it's great to
be back with you and there's no place
for this in American politics the
foundation of this country is about free
and open debate we encourage it we
ultimately placed into the Bill of
Rights the First Amendment to allow
people a freedom of speech to even
criticize their government but not to
resort to violence we actually resolve
our political differences at the ballot
box in America so we've always been
about in this violence the
insightfulness the the call to arms in
essence amongst liberals has to stop
well the left is saying congressman
Scalise that well Donald Trump started
this it's his divisive rhetoric it's a
life or death situation for Americans
are gonna lose their health care women
are gonna lose their right to to
abortion it's a life-and-death situation
well we don't want you to you know
resort to violence but as Mexican water
said push them back find them where they
are go to restaurants gas stations
essentially don't let people operate
like Rudy was doing in public there is
no buts to that sentence and you pointed
that out Laura
but look what this President did when
Donald Trump ran for office he promised
that he would actually fight for those
forgotten men and women there were
millions of Americans that had been left
behind that weren't even part of the
American dream because they had just
been discarded by the previous
administration with a horrible economy
with crazy regulations things that were
killing manufacturing our country and
you literally saw parts of our country
being eviscerated the middle class was
being eviscerated and Donald Trump ran
and said I'm gonna stand up for you his
policies are actually following through
on their congressmen they the less we
understand that way too many of the
Democrats well Eric's wall will came out
in a tweet and he condemned the violence
toward mr. Peters so that's good we
haven't heard very to see more of that
where's my Maxine Waters eaters and
Schumer and Pelosi and where are they
you know a congressional candidate being
attacked with a switchblade
yelling F Trump if and and what does I
got so this is another day and you won't
really need to be called on to call out
this kind of violence if this was going
on on the right you know what happened
Laura every mainstream media outlet
would be reporting this calling on each
one of us they'd have microphones in our
faces will you denounce it and you know
what I would denounce it I don't know
it's anything that happens on either
side but you don't see that enough from
the left and it needs to happen more but
they need to be challenged you know
where are these liberal talk show hosts
that yell and scream and ran rave if
they're incitement is actually leading
somebody to go in and commit violence
but that's not what this country is
about it's by any means necessary and
everyone watching tonight you have to
understand that we're it not for a
switchblade not operating and mr. Peters
having the wherewithal in the physical
strength to push this guy back you might
have had your throat slit and and
congressman Scalise you you came very
close to dying and it could have been a
mass slaughter at that baseball game
that was politically motivated I do not
think it was adequately covered as such
as political violence by the American
media and I get I'm very upset about
what's going on and and Republicans have
to be careful with the rhetoric the
president
everybody has got to take it down a
notch it's way too hot and debate is
great but this is obscene what's
happening mr. Peters a student group
opposed to a speaker on college campuses
you think about what happens at Berkeley
and so forth
check this out do you agree or disagree
that the student groups actions are
acceptable if they resort to violence to
protect to prevent a speaker from
speaking 81% 81% disagree that the
student groups actions are acceptable
that's a good that's you know that's a
good
good deal they shouldn't be violent and
I think young people frankly with their
head screwed on straight most of them
know that Rudy close it out yeah exactly
this gentleman was 35 years old he's not
a child we didn't see him earlier in the
day it's not like we had a dialogue or
an issue or a conflict where he
discussed some policy issues or stances
I don't know what what was in his mind
but you know the latest report is his
mother was with a Democratic Club group
there in that area and she let's make it
really clear and congressman Scalise
knows this this is hatred toward Donald
Trump and his agenda that is it it's not
about the country getting better it's
not about blue-collar workers wages
going up opportunities for
african-americans
it's destroy him by any means necessary
by using any any tool legitimate
illegitimate they do not most of them
just don't care at this point the
teacher of democracy to Laura
they don't respect the things that this
country is founded upon all right
gentlemen thank you so much